Speaker 1: Did George Santos lie about his mom
dying in 911? This is really, really sick stuff.
We're talking about Republican Congressman elect
George Santos, elected by the voters of New York.
He lied about his employment history. He lied
about his educational history. He lied about
being Jewish. He appears to have lied about his
grandparents being refugees from the Holocaust.
He appears to have lied about so many different
things. He is now under criminal investigation.
But here is an explosive new claim. Jorge,
this is a media report. Jorge Santos alleged
that the 911 attacks claimed his mother's life.
And five months later said she died in 2016, 15
years after the 911 attacks. Listen to this.
Yashar Ali flagged these tweets from 2021
last night. These appear to be contradictory
claims, to say the least. On July 12th of 2021,
Jorge Santos tweeted, 911 claimed my
mother's life. 911 claimed my mother's life.
Five months later, in December of 2021, he said
his mom died in December of 2016, which is.
15 years and two months after 911 December.
This is his tweet. December 23rd. This year
marks five years. I lost my best friend and
mentor. Mom, you will live forever in my heart.
Santos campaign website states, quote, George's
mother was in her office in the South Tower
on nine 1121 when the horrific events of that day
unfolded. She survived the tragic events on 911,
but passed away a few years later
when she lost her battle to cancer.
Anybody have any idea what's going on here?
Because I certainly don't. And the article writes,
Although many at Ground Zero in the aftermath
developed health problems like cancer,
15 years is not a few years later. So what of
this is true? I have no idea. As a reminder,
Media Eye reminds us. Santos also claimed he
lost four employees in the 2016 Pulse nightclub
shooting in Orlando. However, none of the 49
people killed are linked to any of the places
that he even claimed to have worked, which is a
whole other story. I don't know what the truth is,
but it is natural to be extraordinarily
skeptical given the disgusting nature of
this guy's lies. Now, is he ultimately going
to be forced into resignation? I don't know.
We're running out of time. I believe he should
be. He has shown a willingness to lie for what
he believes to be personal gain. But also, even
if you want to argue or suggest that there are
other motivations, like, for example, he's just
a pathological liar. There are people who it's
almost reflexive. They just lie. They lie, they
lie. They like you know, I I've told a couple
stories. I was reminded of another person I know
where it was like a reflex. It was quite literally
a reflex. And I remember having a conversation
with them where I said, Oh yeah, you know,
like at the time we were, I think we were using
constant contact for email where I go, Yeah, we,
we use a service called Constant
Contact for email. They're actually,
you know, they're pretty good or something.
And the person said, Oh yeah, my uncle works at
constant contact. And I said, Oh really? Because
constant contact space like in the Boston suburbs.
I didn't know you had to go. No. Well, yeah, he
works remotely for them. Oh, it wasn't true. Just.
Just. It's natural, natural instinct to just lie,
lie, lie. If that's part of what is going on here
with George Santos, that also doesn't make me
a particularly good candidate to be a member of
the House of Representatives. So we'll see what
happens in the next couple of days. The pressure
to resign is mounting. The criminal probe is a
real problem at this point, and that may be what
pushes him over the edge into resignation. But
at the same time, he may be one of 435 members
of Congress starting next week, which would
be yet another embarrassment and humiliation
for the United States. Not to the degree of Trump
being president, certainly, but it will certainly
be a humiliation. We're going to try to get him
on the show. I would love for him to tell us in
his own words what all of this is about. I don't
know that he's going to accept that invitation.